westernunion rund um die welt schnell
wie es auf der suche nach dem glück geht
der mensch zuweilen weite wege das
paradies lehnen wir meist dort wo wir
nicht sind in der ferne
tausende von schweizerinnen und
schweizern wandern jedes jahr aus und
wagen ein neues leben im ausland
sie träumen von der großen freiheit den
kanada sie sehnen sich nach der sonne
der karibik
letztes jahr begleiteten wir fünf
familien beim abenteuer ihres lebens
jetzt haben wir sie alle noch einmal
besucht wie geht es ihnen heute haben
sie ihr glück gefunden
[Musik]
so sah es aus als die auswanderer vor
einem jahr den großen schritt wagten
blicken wir zurück dina und kevin
schmidt tochter amira und söhnchen
rohren
sie suchten ihr glück in australien der
ehemalige tagesschau moderator hans jörg
enz zog als entwicklungshelfer in die
demokratische republik kongo
monika johnny und ihr mann reto ihre
beiden töchter chiara und selina sie
machten den wüstenstaat dubai zu ihrem
neuen zuhause
sandra gal und ihr mann danken träumten
vom eigenen bauernhof in kanada der ispo
nett und klausur candrian sehnten sich
nach dem tropischen klima der karibik
[Musik]
oktober 2008 sieben jahre lang arbeitete
sandra und danken gar auf dem golfplatz
unterengstringen im kanton zürich danken
pflegte den rasen und sandra führte das
büro doch sie träumten von einem anderen
leben sparten jeden franken für einen
eigenen bauernhof in kanada wo sie
stehen
mit david kommen
[Musik]
ihr paradies liegt in der wildnis von
manitoba
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir leben viele kojoten und wenig
menschen
[Musik]
sie war ein geschenk
ja
[Musik]
denn solange
doch
liebscher
die ohren
zwischen frau musste
mit den flaggen
dafür kann
zwischen der erfolg des glauben verloren
[Musik]
mit diesem prozess soll am 3
so viel vorstellen
schlamm
das ist ihr neues zuhause
sie haben es bei ihrem ersten besuch vor
einigen monaten gekauft die vorbesitzer
haben das fertighaus aus den 60er jahren
erst vor zwei tagen geräumt
[Musik]
duncan erfüllt sich einen kindheitstraum
erst von dem bauernhof in nord amerika
aufgewachsen
die gelernte sekretärin sandra betritt
neuland
die beiden haben ein riesiges stück land
direkt am lake manitoba gekauft es ist
800 hektaren gross
ausrüster kann aber ich find's cool und
es da einfach folgendes bitte vor gott
im himmel oder arbeitet das zunehmend zu
angestellten wo es während der ganzen
zeit laufen dann hätten wir nicht einen
tag über zwölf kilometer ausstoßen
[Musik]
september 2008 in ruby im kanton st
gallen
tina schmidt telefoniert mit ihrem mann
käme erst bereits sie ihrer neuen heimat
in australien in der alice springs hat
er für die familie ein haus gemietet die
29 jährige sieht es zum ersten mal per
computer kamera und dann die situation
nun bestimme gefalle service ist es dass
man mir das vorgestellt hat ist es so
wie es aussah wochen weiterhin
vorstellen und dann entscheiden bliebe
mit entschied dann halt die schuhe
so wie jesus ist ein begriff aus der
schule sein erwidert oder es ist keine
baustelle ist überhaupt nicht so wie wir
sie drohend hand oder bank kommt dann
qe3
das ist präsenter und glück schmecken
nach und familien und bodo ahnt nicht
was ihm bevorsteht
zum glück
[Musik]
die das miterlebt
der schweizer sennenhund begleitet seine
familie nach australien
wegen der strengen gesetze dort muss er
als erstes vier wochen in quarantäne
[Musik]
herbst 2008 im kanton graubünden nach 30
jahren als lokführer der rhätischen bahn
hat claudio candrian die nase voll vom
leben nach fahrplan
seine partnerin theres brünett hat 20
jahre auf der post in chur gearbeitet
auch sie will mehr vom leben als ein
wenig freizeit nach schalterschluss isla
margarita eine kleine insel für große
träume im touristenparadies wollen
theres brünett und claudio candrian ein
haus bauen und damit vor allem eines tun
nichts
der einheimische ppr wird ihnen auf den
weg durch den behördendschungel helfen
das werden wir uns runter und darüber
dass schiedsrichter tätig ist sowieso
lieferbar das ist ja kulturland für das
grundstück haben tieres und claudio
bereits umgerechnet 10.000 franken an
bezahlt alles ist das gros lama die
hauptstadt der insel in der kanzler-
ihre anwältin soll der feierlichen
moment der vertragsunterzeichnung
stattfinden dann sind sie offiziell
landbesitzer in venezuela
[Applaus]
da hat sich ein kontakt
die bündner haben sich zu früh gefreut
der vertrag sei noch nicht aufgesetzt
und sowieso müsse man über den landkreis
noch einmal reden verkündet die anwältin
statt 50 millionen dosen
da wird viel geredet und wenig macht zum
anderen ist wohl in der moschee zum
leckeren
das land dann richtig
jetzt will man rechner
[Musik]
dezember 2008 monika mazzoni räumt mit
ihren töchtern chiara und selina das
haus in dem sie zehn jahre lang gelebt
haben als frau eines linienpiloten der
auf der ganzen welt arbeitet ist sie es
gewohnt auch solche große aufgaben
alleine anzupacken
der ehemalige swissair pilot reto
mazzoni ist bereits nach dubai
vorausgereist wo er seit einigen monaten
arbeitet
[Musik]
hier am flughafen tritt der pilot der
fluglinie emirates sonst seinen dienst
an
heute kann er nach wochen der trennung
endlich seine familie in der neuen
heimat empfangen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dubai ist eine boomende hightech stadt
die in wenigen jahren aus dem wüstensand
gestampft wurde
[Musik]
hier leben macho nis in zukunft
das ist nicht so dass man sagen zwei
monaten sie die kohle heiden mit als 80
menschen das ganze mal gebaut worden
[Musik]
straubing
die contest machen
[Applaus]
sie stiegen die provinzhauptstadt bukavu
im osten der demokratischen republik
kongo
[Musik]
armut und bewaffnete konflikte prägen
das leben
hilfswerke versuchen den menschen ein
wenig lebensqualität zu ermöglichen
für eines von ihnen arbeitet hansjörg
enz autofahren geplant ist wie früher
als kinder vom autoscooter dass man
hatte anderen autos weg und der mit
links und rechts und zwei problem ist
dass und re gehört und war mit einer
weißen kutsche teilung des landes zeigen
der ehemalige tagesschau moderator
arbeitet im auftrag eines deutschen
hilfswerkes bei radio bei der leo wird
er in den nächsten zwei jahren in
verschiedenen bereichen tätig sein
ist das wagnis jahr
[Gelächter]
das studio zwei dollar auf 70 acentic da
ist gespielt wird über kassette aber zu
selten die herrschaft nova lautet bukavu
liegt am chiemsee hansjörg enz begleitet
seine neuen arbeitskollegen den hafen
die journalisten machen eine reportage
über die ankunft eines schiffes mit
flüchtlingen in goma am anderen ende des
sees verbreitet ein kriegstreiber angst
und schrecken
hansjörg enz soll die radioreporter den
nächsten zwei jahren ausbilden und ihren
sinn für fairen journalismus schärfen
während der die journalisten ausbildet
bekommt hansjörg enz selber eine lektion
in afrikanische realität eine realität
die seine heimat ist
die besucher jetzt leben muss und unter
der vorgabe zu den gastransit mich sagen
der winter hat ein problem und da ziert
sie stiegen mit der frage wo kommen
[Musik]
er ließ brings hat rund 30.000
einwohnern
rapid- schmid empfängt seine familie in
der neuen heimat
[Musik]
es gebe zwei wochen
hülsbergen
[Musik]
familie schmid war noch nie in alice
springs
da wurden alle strassen aber als
schwieriges findet ivt tsunami
dina und die kinder sehen ihre neue
heimat heute zum ersten mal alles was
drin nicht genug frauen
alice springs liegt mitten in der wüste
bis zur nächsten größeren stadt sind es
rund 1500 kilometer
überhaupt ist ein flugzeug hat mit einer
phase da ebenso gut anziehen weil sie
schlecht wir stehen und dann als groß
ein sixcup man glauben dass hinter mir
eine dame auf der residenzstraße bin und
dann ist man froh und dann habe ich
gesagt weil die drei autos sie dann bin
ich die großstadt und von u2 und dann
habe ich mich total aber sieht sich
jetzt da bin und was ist mit suppe
kaffeemaschine ist nur besser und im
vorstand kommt noch immer offiziell aber
das sieht ein kreis so schlimm jetzt mit
großer lockig oder jetzt fehlt nur noch
eine sogenannte bochum
modus einsame wochen in der quarantäne
sind endlich vorbei
der schweizer sennenhund ist wieder bei
seiner familie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hey
[Musik]
jetzt immer komplett wieder zusammen
in kanada haben sandra und danken gar
nooke gekauft sie wollen von der
sogenannten mutterkuhhaltung leben das
heißt sie züchten kälber und sie dann
möglichst teuer auf auktionen zu
verkaufen
hp kauft roche ist
[Musik]
schlecht
man habe den tod
[Musik]
ein kalb bringt nicht nur freude sondern
später hoffentlich möglichst viel geld
in die kasse von sander und danken ihre
herde wächst mit jedem tag
[Musik]
das ist nicht so
durch dunkings alltag ist oft alles
andere als [ __ ] herzig nach der
geglückten geburt macht ihm ein anderes
kalb sorgen dabei danken ist extrem
gefordert
hier draußen kommt der tierarzt nur im
äußersten notfall und das kalb will
einfach nicht trinken
hamann auf der isla margarita in
venezuela ziehen wolken auf
claudio candrian ahnt nichts gutes als
er sein grundstück besucht
[Musik]
dann entdeckt claudio auch noch ein
schild das an land zum verkauf anpreist
[Musik]
freund telefoniert wieder verkäuferin
normal
und damit
[Musik]
konfusion ja locker heißt verrückt
claudio hat bereits ein wichtiges
spanisches wort gelernt
er wird es noch häufig gebrauchen freund
pps bietet den lokalen polizeichef auf
der soll die konfusion klären die hand
des gesetzes ist hier in venezuela
irgendwie lockerer als in der schweiz
[Musik]
das diplomatisch
dubai im april 2009 familie mazzoni
bezieht nach wochen im hotel endlich ihr
haus in der greenfield community
[Musik]
jahr aus und weiß noch mal etwas zähnen
endspiel
die lena freut sich auf ihr geliebtes
klavier im eigenen zimmer
doch die zügel männer verkünden das
klavier sei viel zu schwer um es in den
ersten stock zu tragen
das bereitet hocker ist es nicht und es
ist ja auch nicht so gross wie die
schweiz
selinas tränen und die schweizerische
hartnäckigkeit ihrer mutter machen
schließlich selbst die schwächsten zügen
stark
[Musik]
[Applaus]
monika mann toni versichert den
erschöpften züge männern die selina aber
immer vom klavier im eigenen zimmer
geträumt
[Musik]
den rest des umzuges muss sie alleine
meistern ihr mann rät ulbricht wieder
einmal auf er hat einen einsatz als
pilot ein chauffeur seiner airline holt
ihn ab
[Musik]
august
als erwartet aus ihrer passiven und
schlossen wir eigentlich mit seiner
stammband
ja und ich sehe mich auch jetzt macht er
selbst antiken dankes braucht obwohl die
reise bis nach bombay geht mit reto
mazzoni nur zwei tage von seiner familie
weg sein früher von der schweiz aus war
jeweils viel länger unterwegs
[Musik]
in bukavu arbeiteten die journalisten
von radio de leo bisher mit uralten
kassetten geräten und schrieben die
nachrichten von hand hansjörg enz hat
zwei techniker aus der schweiz
organisiert die ein neues studio und
computer einbauen werden
finanziert durch spendengelder
der 17-malige meister und und darauf
dann klar gemacht wie sehr einfach wenn
gesetzgeber jetzt nicht deckt oder wenn
mal etwas gar einfach und das wirkt
lange nicht war doch gar nicht auf ihn
gehört doch zum ersten mal glaube immer
auch leute drauf
als weißer kann es sich hansjörg enz
leisten im westen wohnviertel bukarest
zu leben er hat sich im haus alle
anderen entwicklungshelferin eingemietet
hinunter stock und da ist schlafzimmer
dass sie drüben niveau einfach stellt
damit wird und sobald wir ihm machen
dass sie zur sache um sich verhöhnt das
strom
jeden tag eins seines falter dass man
kallas davon was in der theorie da wo
die wiese wohnen daher mir relativ viel
strom und relativ viel wasser durch
küche was wird da viele der stars
wirklich
die musikvielfalt überhaupt einen kauf
des fc
wenn sie denn überhaupt
könnt ihr paradies sieht auch udo
melodik sieht man überall wie die user
zu stören und stachelt vor 20 jahren zog
sie daheim uhr kann da hat man nach
einer freien behält leben natürlich
sicherheitsrats einfach zu viele waffen
oder bereit sind hat die waffe zu buchen
und zitiert oder wohnen im uhren- und
die bankerin und wächter und dass man
sperrt sich selber richtig ist eine
wunderschöne land hat man sich bisher
nicht so einfach zu träge
[Musik]
in kanada ist er lange weder vorbei doch
der frühling brachte für sandra und
danken gar nichts gutes
[Musik]
statt über auf fünf bis zehn zentimeter
wasser das ist einfach verlorenes geld
das eigene foto ist ruiniert danken wird
es teuer bei anderen bau und kaufen
müssen
das ist einfach mein geschäft nichts los
also schnitte es ist nicht so dramatisch
wie es vielleicht mit skipper wenn wir
den doch drittel dritter da habe ich
auch verbünden machen glaube verkauf
gott graz gerade großes stück weg die
kosten für den snack straßen unterwegs
oder gar nuss haben bisher nur geld
ausgegeben und noch nichts verdient um
zu sparen nutzer anregen ihren garten
eden als gemüsebeet auf ihrem konto
herrscht schon bald etwas machen kann
noch weiß anderer gar nicht dass der
große zahltag ausbleiben wird weil die
kälber versteigerung in einem
finanziellen desaster endet
[Musik]
in alice springs errichtet familie
schmid ihr neues zuhause ein der ganz
gewöhnliche alltag hat sie eingeholt
[Musik]
auch im paradies kämpfen familienväter
mit dem typen von selbst bei möbeln und
mütter ringen um fassung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jochen späth alte heimat fans nochmal
spiele
man hätte den politischen druck hin
inzwischen dass ihnen der blick
erstaunen
[Musik]
auf der isla margarita hat der landkauf
nach vielen irrungen und wirrungen doch
noch geklappt
theres pronet und claudio candrian
besuchen die baustelle ihres hauses
[Musik]
bruder wieder jetzt rigoros
gebaut wird nach schweizer pläne
geändert york auf die baubewilligung
noch die hände
eigentlich medien bauplan hätte starten
können mache hätte schmerzen ein
architekt er hätte dieses messen
absegnen und der hätte für das die hohle
hand gemacht drittens 5 millionen mit
dir foto gemeint sondern im vereinsjahr
ein genie tiger hellmann den kauf die
drei architekten der jeder 1,5 millionen
wähler und der könnte mit einer bleibe
was gehört ist nie wieder
aber das ist 1500 franken
bestechungsgeld mussten die beiden
hinblättern damit sie ihre ruhe haben
denn darum sind sie hierher gekommen um
das paradies zu genießen und sonst
nichts zu tun
zumindest hatten sie sich das
vorgenommen
[Musik]
doch dem lokführer mit 30 jahren
berufserfahrung wurde es auf dem
abstellgleis schnell langweilig
[Musik]
seit claudio candrian nicht mehr
arbeiten muss sondern darauf erholt er
sich fast täglich in der garage eine
schweizer kollegen von dolce far niente
[Musik]
schöneberger bis ihr haus endlich fertig
ist wohnen theres brünett und claudio
candrian zur miete vor kurzem hat er es
eine begegnung im paradies die alles
andere als pazifik also friedlich war
[Musik]
eröffnet und dann aber richtig
so muss man es nicht kommen
und in dem moment schoss losgegangen
und dann eine gewisse für schock kann
und vielleicht schmerzen american oder
was auch immer arbeiten job druck macht
also zum glück nur sehr streifschuss
kräfte die ganz laute geschobenen
anzusehen und mehr zum glück nicht ins
gesicht
[Musik]
die business metropole dubai ist ein
magnet für auswanderer aus der ganzen
welt
private schulen mit englischunterricht
buben chiara und selina haben heute
ihren ersten schultag
[Musik]
selina trägt zwar schon die gleiche
uniform wie ihre neuen klassenkameraden
aber im gegensatz zu ihnen spricht sie
kaum ein wort englisch wie alt bist du
geburtstag
wenn die geburtstag
ist das kein elend st
die 20
[Applaus]
welches buch aufnehmen
das ist selina sie kommt aus der schweiz
sie spricht noch ganz wenig englisch ich
möchte dass du dich und celina kümmerst
matilda um dir zeigt wo turnen
französisch und deutsch stattfinden
auch chiara ist die einzige in ihrer
klasse die noch kaum englisch spricht
eines ist in berlin ein hund ist
[Musik]
ja
dabei denkt daran wie es spielen von
euch ging als ihr ohne englisch zu
verstehen nach dubai gekommen seid als
ja kaum etwas verstanden hat was glaubt
ihr können wir machen und jahre zu
helfen
wir können ja alles erklären gut jahre
soll teil unseres teams sein
in alice springs arbeitet ketsch mit als
touristenführer wieder einmal packte den
anhänger für einen mehrtägigen tritt
eine belastende situation für die kleine
amira und ihre mutter dina
musste
jena
jugendlich
kevin schmid ist rund 20 tage im monat
von china und den kindern weg er ist
sich bewusst was er ihn damit antut
[Musik]
und so hat er vielleicht total
der schuss
dagegen der 1
wo es bei 300
das muss diskutiert
hi
vin sda
[Musik]
sie wüssten dass strahlenschäden groß
dass du dich dennoch in ordnung
das heißt es lange wenn vorher größte
die vor mir überhaupt nicht mehr
durchschauen geräte durchaus hören
lassen können
immerhin gut
[Musik]
in der region und wo gruppen in den
letzten jahrzehnten schreckliche
bürgerkriege die bevölkerung ist
leidgeprüft und betragen es fehlt an den
elementarsten dingen hansjörg 1 lebt
mitten in disneyland nebst seiner arbeit
beim radio setzt sich unter anderem für
ein mädchen ein die man die schule
bezahlt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
solch unbeschwerte momente in der schule
sind selten im kongo bekommt nur ein
kleiner teil der kinder eine ausbildung
die meisten eltern können sich das
schulgeld nicht leisten
das ist sie mir das patenkind von
hansjörg enz
so wie sie mir zeigt dem weißen mann aus
der schweiz wie sie lebt dank seiner
hilfe kann sie als einzige von sieben
geschwistern zur schule gehen die eltern
verdienen mit ihrer kleinen
bananenplantage nicht einmal genug um
die familie richtig zu ernähren und zu
schaffen bleibt der familie mit acht
kindern schuluniform ist ihnen durch das
ständige fahne da gibt es aber nicht
[Musik]
bei radio bandelow ist das letzte kabel
des neuen studios angeschlossen
der schweizer techniker philipp koller
erklärt haben sich agents das neue
mischpult und den zeitungsmann alles
material als offenes messer und
nationalismus seit redaktorin besucher
wenn das in zehn tagen ab gefahren durch
die trümmerhalden ich fünf sekunden und
die laufzeit mit dem ziehen was macht
verhindern abfahren
und da ich ständig sie mit der maus und
14 monate hat hansjörg enz auf diesen
moment hingearbeitet
sie halten ihr versprechen bedankt sich
ein moderator
auf der isla margarita zieht sich der
hausbau nun schon seit neun monaten hin
theres pro nette und claudio candrian
besuchen die baustelle fast täglich
[Musik]
zweiter fenster jetzt trotz spruch zu
hoher oder vielmehr verdoppelt
einfach organisieren uns nicht dauerhaft
europa werden
wenn dir so schafer würden wie die erde
das ist nicht ob sie läuft noch wissen
die beiden nicht dass dies erst der
anfang von einem langen leidensweg ist
es wird noch mehr als ein jahr vergehen
bis sie die aussicht auf ihr paradies
genießen können
[Musik]
november 2010
vor einigen wochen haben wie es anderer
und danken gar noch einmal besucht wie
geht es ihnen nach zwei jahren in ihrem
paradies
heute schauen sie sich an wie alles
angefangen hat
[Musik]
solon
hier oben
zwischen
medlock
nach der anfänglichen begeisterung
stellte sich im paradies schnell die
ernüchterung ein
wir sind da wo man wirklich auf jede
dollar gemeint das ist mühsam und extrem
mühsam gewesen
das könnte man ganz großer techniker mit
dem traktor oder durch sicherheit
durchaus noch so strang schaffen und gut
zu der tiere und durchblicke garantie
was den andi jahr für die menschen da
das nur ein nicht im jahr wenn überhaupt
für die lehrerzahl gescher verschnitt
von budgetiert oder eben wie man das
land machen
sandra und dank ungarn arbeiten tag für
tag zusammen
sie sind ein eingespieltes team fast
alle arbeiten auf dem hof meistern sie
alleine heute impfen sie jene kälber die
sie für die weiterzucht behalten
doch die kälber zucht ist weit weniger
einträglich als sie gemeint haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
am 1
die jährliche fraktion ist ihre einzige
einnahmequelle letztes jahr endete sie
in einem finanziellen desaster
sandra und danken verdienten mit dem
verkauf ihrer kälber weniger als sie für
deren aufzucht ausgegeben haben
ein minusgeschäft machtlos mussten sie
zusehen wie die bieter einen viel zu
tiefen preis ausgehandelt haben
dann kaufte die ganz abhängigkeit von
meinem ort um mit lost rufen dass ich
habe somit dort darunter stand während
der verhandlung die hier gute halbe und
infizieren strafe wenn der markt nicht
gut ist ich kann mir noch so gut vom
markt bringen und das ist sie warum in
kalkar verkauft hätten die diesjährige
kälber versteigerung war erfolgreicher
trotzdem decken ihre einnahmen nur knapp
die ausgaben wieder ein frustrierender
lohn für endlose stunden harter arbeit
die beiden machen alles richtig kommen
aber auf keinen grünen zweig
sie haben immer von ihrem eigenen
bauernhof geträumt nun geben sie diesen
traum auf sie wollen ihr paradies
verkaufen wo es stinkt nicht also kann
ich mir das nicht vorstellen und da habe
ich für mich bevor ich überhaupt eine
liste gemacht was sind hier könnte wo
veränderbar sind aber das haus
infrastruktur wo mich gestörten zum teil
und sachen wo nicht man kann keinen
einfluss drauf und es sind nur drei
fluss daraufhin war wirklich ganz große
knackpunkt sind muss ich sagen dass das
langfristig so wieder machen
[Musik]
mit der frage wohin
september 2010 endlich steht das
traumhaus von der ispo nett und claudio
candrian macht er stimmung und macht
wenn man da hätte man die hoch nicht nur
geld wählen und gemacht hätten dass
dieses thema nicht ganz kräftig fällt
später sind sie zwar york also der arme
hat mit der china gemacht jetzt muss er
dennoch mit basler tor und da schaue mir
jetzt aber hey meine tochter ist immer
noch nicht einmal was man darüber machen
sich das fenster öffnen
puma habe wenn es regnet und das gerade
hören dafür am rande bauer
da bin ich schon bisschen husten und dem
husten den cut nach der show viel zeit
und vom selber hat denkt man nur für 12
hält ist aufgeklärt
zu zweit sind die beiden nicht mehr die
straßen darunter alegra emma und reiser
sind ebenfalls ins traumhaus eingezogen
im tropischen klima spielt sich das
leben auf der terrasse an mitte auf und
davon dvd blickend er ist brünett und
claudio kanton bern zurück auf die
schier endlosen bauarbeiten zwischen
sieht ja musiker gang zurückschalten
will auf die zweifache mutter
doch und der wunsch als europäer im
gegenteil wenn jetzt dauert druck
gemacht ich kann jetzt dazu mehr und so
diskret dass er nicht so gern an der
rückseite wenn dort druck macht wird
noch schlimmer und das
du musst einfach gefällt das ist das
organisieren ist einfach nicht stärke
von denen los ist rufen wir wahnsinnig
du musst nach fast notierte papier
kaufen damit den studien ufer schön aber
im nachhinein mir hängt ja da musst du
einfach alles gelaufen denn alles
werkzeug alles was ich falsch moerser
verstehen meine teehändler bauplan
karriere ist und man hätte ihnen das
werkzeug verwirklicht stellt man hier
das material zur verfügung gestellte er
ist und denn laub und wenn du da nicht
macht hat der druck da besitzt das jetzt
darf und zum beispiel sind ja so toll
ist das ist es ja was ist aber dass er
hat sich dirk nervt absacker wo
eigentlich gar nichts mehr fixies sind
wird davor was ist da gesperrt
sie stiegen
die linke mit david kommen september
2010 in australien haben amira und rohan
ein schwesterchen bekommen
fiona heißt das dritte kind von dina und
kevin schmid wollte können sie alle
wieder lachen
doch sie haben schwere zeiten hinter
sich im januar wurde cage mit seiner
tochter amira zeigen wie man velo fährt
die schwere geschichte gefangen und
schulter gebrochen hat und alle sind
immer auch eine waffe bedient
[Musik]
du hast eine kleine schafe
unveröffentlichte tutor begeben
gibt's doch nicht und das ist genau was
sie sich noch zeit beschäftige stehen
eine stunde lang über rom
und das hat dann bedeutet das mir vier
wochen nach der beendigung von
arbeitsverhältnissen ist es wissen dann
abgehakt wir haben das wiso mich mit dem
arbeitgeber im zimmer und schauen wann
die job verliert oder niemand was machen
und ausland und dann hat sich relativ
dramatisch zugespitzt das ganze im
gesetz steht aber nicht was passiert
wenn dieser schweizer kurzerhand sein
eigener arbeitgeber wird mit diesem
kniff überzeugte tablet schmid die
einwanderungsbehörde
dank der finanziellen unterstützung von
freunden und familie konnte er eine
firma kaufen
dieses logo auf computer business mit
nur 100 verschiedene
[Applaus]
was als verzweifeltes mittel zum zweck
begonnen hatte entwickelte sich in den
letzten monaten zu einer florierenden
firma weiss ich nicht verrückt sondern
technisch beziehen sind herausgestellt
dass das doch ich mich als ich selber
machen
marien kunden geschaffen
bis vor dem einfamilienhaus würden
techniker der techniker ist gut und
somit geht es nur mehr opportun zu wiegt
also linie volkstod techniker toni ist
heillos überlastet
darum sucht ketsch mit bereits einen
weiteren angestellten
die beiden können sich vor aufträgen
kaum retten
zum beispiel springs flughafen und die
werden sie große organisationen eines
autos auf unserer liste
früher nervte sich kevin schmid wenn die
ach so vorbildlichen schweizer tugenden
gepriesen wurden heute begeistert er die
kunden just mit diesen tugenden
pünktlichkeit und zuverlässigkeit in
einer kleinen stadt wie alice springs
spricht sich so etwas schnell herum um
alle aufträge erledigen zu können hat
karl schmid bereits einen zweiten
geschäftswagen bestellt weil es hier so
viele tolle spielzeuge gibt bistro an
immer gerne dabei wenn mami dina seine
schwester im kindergarten abholt
angeschaut und das buch dieses jahres
will sie damit in dem strich und wenn
sie für sich gespielt aber mit dem roman
spielt und man redet und rechts an und
da ihren teilzeitjob in einem café hat
dina schmid aufgegeben als sie im
brütend heißen australischen sommer mit
leona schwanger bei mit ihren kindern
ist sie rund um die uhr ausgelastet
da kann ist kein anders anhören und das
ja ein wirklich wichtiges mittel
zusammen und unterhalten sich ausmachen
man hat schon mal weniger wachsen aber
auch sonst dichtungs klasse dieser
wildfang heißt ali er ist der neue
kumpel von bordeaux eigentlich wollte
die nach schmied sobald die kinder älter
sind wieder auf ihren gelernten beruf
als krankenschwester arbeiten dort ihre
ausbildung wird hier in australien nicht
anerkannt
[Applaus]
sie spiegeln ihre säcke mit der frage wo
kommen wir hin
september 2010 in dubai reto und monika
macho nie
schauen sie die auswanderer serie noch
einmal an sie zogen an den hauptsitz von
ritus arbeitgeber weil sie hofften
dadurch künftig mehr zeit für sich und
die familie zu haben
und das noch dazu auch unseren sie
wacker morgen das schon bis zum frühen
nachmittag also mir alle wände ein
biometrie sauber wollte schweiz haut und
für kinder meint rosi also von damals
ist der hauptgrund warum das ist
verdammt
monika hat sony bringt chiara und selina
jeden tag mit dem auto zur schule in
dubai ist das so üblich
selina weiß nicht so recht ob sie stolz
oder ob es hier peinlich sein soll dass
sie vom schweizer fernsehen in ihre
klasse begleitet wird
[Musik]
laut einzuweisen
die linos klassenkameradinnen und
kameraden kommen aus der ganzen welt
sie alle haben eltern die in dubai
arbeiten sie li na hat kaum mehr kontakt
zu ihren schulfreundinnen in der schweiz
sie hat hier schnell einen neuen
freundeskreis gefunden und auch chiara
hat sich bestens eingelebt
einmal in der woche hat klara
deutschunterricht weil in allen anderen
fächern englisch gesprochen wird muss
die schule darauf achten dass die kinder
ihre muttersprache nicht verlernen
der s p
mathe und physiklehrer oder mathe und
physiklehrer nicht besonders nett ja ich
habe mich besonders in der sonne gleich
kinder beim kinder nicht
auch im paradies lebt der ehemalige
lokführer claudio candrian nach einem
strikten fahrplan jeden morgen macht er
den gleichen spaziergang und jeden
morgen genießt er den sonnenaufgang
dass er seine erwachsenen söhne aus
erster ehe nur noch selten sieht ist der
preis für das neue glück
o
gedanken könnten schon zur familie
vor allem der sommermorgen allein aber
den teint schneidewind schön locker mal
wie schön dass du hast ihn jedoch fast
immer
heute ist in europa der gmbh überlegen
kommt immer wieder der herr johannes
stein und nehme jedes mal und stein mit
der hand wird das pendel größtes von tag
zu tag
damit kommt immer so ginge da china
[Musik]
du bist du bist so nach oben aber damit
an das versprüht die stimmen müssen die
daten an abenden und das heißt wenn
baurecht die ordnung
wir sind schon morgen den kanal können
wir den krach offenthal bewegung kann
nix mehr sind als touristen aufgabe
jedes mal jeder abschnitt ist wieder
aufgegangen
davon hatten sie immer geträumt was sich
andere für viel geld zwei wochen im jahr
leisten haben sie jeden tag den
traumstrand vor der haustür nur seit sie
ihr leben
das sind sie oft wochenlang nicht am
strand die pflicht claudio hat viel
arbeit in der garage und die rest
verbringt jeden tag stündigen wird
putzarbeiten im neuen haus
[Musik]
die sprache haben sie mittlerweile
gelernt aber das karibische talent zur
großen lockerheit ist den schweizern
noch nicht ins blut übergegangen wir
effektiv leben
natürlich sind natürlich fotos laden die
natürlich gerade der stadt wenn alles
friedlich
und da liegt jetzt der studentenwerke
war stand 0 war schon zumute man sagt es
gebe nicht viele
dies sind alles brings aushalten doch
wer hier hängen bleibe der werde
glücklich
dina und kevin schmid gehören zu diesen
menschen
[Musik]
das schicksal der jungen schweizer
familie
die wegen einer gebrochenen schulter
beinahe ihre geliebte neue heimat hätte
verlassen müssen schaffte es bis in die
zeitung
wenn du anderthalb jahre überall nur
abgrundtief und zurückwiesen
[Musik]
die druckmedien zum dass familien
ermöglicht ist einfach immer größer war
schon verzweifelt ist es muss doch jetzt
muss davon merkt sie dass leute waren
schaffte wo bildet sind wir in der
familie an
schlussendlich muss krise wäre die
situation erschien so aussichtslos dass
china und cabot im internet ein haus in
der schweiz suchten das ende ihres
australischen traumes schien besiegelt
diener und kate war nervlich am ende und
stritten fiel sogar eine trennung stand
im raum
[Musik]
von den schweden wieder kraft also ja
wenn man vom tage oder im amt vom
stressigen alltag sie sich immer noch
die richtige es stimmt dann ist gut und
das ist also und ein dezentes grau wie
die krebsmittel wenn man habe zusammen
im bett liegt und einfach viel sogar
also ziel erreicht familien ist ein
binnenland und jetzt haben wir sogar
wieder so richtig schön
[Musik]
hansjörg enz lebt wieder in frauenfeld
im september kehrte er wie geplant aus
der demokratischen republik kongo zurück
unterrichtet wie früher an der zürcher
hochschule winterthur
daneben arbeitet arbeiter für projekte
in afrika 14 monate hatten sex auf
diesen moment hingearbeitet
die freude der schweizer
entwicklungshelfer sein engagement als
ausbildner und modernisierer bei
radio-in de leo ist abgeschlossen
es muss jetzt auf eigenen beinen stehen
wollen nach ihren träumen können
schlechte führung das schaut ja also das
ist ja es ist max kruse thema religion
ist der kongo wäre land mit wahnsinnig
viele chancen aber irgendwann realisiert
und radiomann der leone radio mit ganz
viel chance märkte für schwierig
struktur ist noch nicht da was könnt sie
dass das eis oder verstorben
[Musik]
zwei jahre lebte er am ufer des
chiemsees heute spaziert hansjörg enz
wie früher am nussbaumer see
er ist zurück in der heilen und
wohlbehüteten schweiz aber der schwarze
kontinent hat spuren hinterlassen
[Musik]
ja es ist die einfachste wieder sagen
dass jeder darum wieder tritt finden
und ich bin ja schon wieder so half und
ein vorbereiter wieder vertrugen adwords
gold einfach alles ist auf drei jetzt
bringen mit diesen job nicht machen
kompliziert ist einfach im netz
vorgestellt und die märkte dass ich
wenig zeit zum nebenwirkung mal erholen
die filme so ziemlich ja auch ziemlich
ziemlich stressig sein werden so schnell
durch war
statt das ich schreibe lieber mehreren
zurück ist
und da ist das kkd situation
der 59 jährige war nach afrika gegangen
um sich als entwicklungshelfer einen
lang gehegten traum zu erfüllen
er kommt zurück im schmerzlichen
bewusstsein wie wenig er in der harten
realität afrikas ausrichten konnte
aber sonst eine grundsätzliche großes
vor gezahlt was was was sind eigentlich
aber sowas wo war gott sie dem label
magath zwar menschlich auf das was ist
das genau
[Applaus]
ja ich weiß nicht krisen ich hatte also
kontakt egal aber das muss ich natürlich
hoffe dass du so tragisch nein ich denke
dass wir das verhältnis hat hinter zudem
aber aber womit sie schon mal finden
[Musik]
sandra und danken gano haben
unterschätzt wie hart das bauernleben
ist darum geben sie ihren hof auf sie
wollen aber in kanada bleiben und haben
neue träume schönsten das hüsli hand
teilzeitjob genug verdienen schottern
wirklich was sagen kann im winter und
freis machen im süden etwa wo du einfach
zeit für sport dach limacher bis neues
lehrer und savannah knies nach einem
fluss wo entweder für alle drin herzens
mit frischer fliegen fliegerfest hobby
könnte unterstütze und offenland aber
ich möchte eine botschaft oder könnt ihr
freunde unterhalten und nationalpark
skigebiet dem spiel die wende
hier hoffen frisches futter
bis sie an den käufer gefunden haben
machen sandra und danken weiter sie
hoffen dass land und den hof für rund
eine halbe million franken verkaufen zu
können
das wäre ein gutes startkapital für
ihren neuen traum vielleicht hätten sie
sich blauäugig in dieses abenteuer
gestürzt
aber ein fehler sei ihr traum auf gar
keinen fall gewesen
im gegenteil wenn sie es nicht versucht
hätten hätten sie es ein leben lang
bereut
sandra und danken sind glücklich weil
sie das glück suchen
wann sie es finden ist nicht so wichtig
[Musik]
seit motto nis in dubai leben verbringen
sie tatsächlich viel mehr zeit zusammen
mitten in der wüste haben sie sich ihre
eigene oase geschaffen
[Musik]
einfach ausprobieren jetzt von neuem man
einfach zusammen aber jetzt glauben
ihnen schreiben einfach seit jahren zwei
mal zu probieren weil es nach wie vor
einfach spannend für mich frauenberg der
spruch im englischen luton
hier könne keine lehren bereit alles für
hatte die schweiz hat die das nicht
können ist einfach alles
selinas klavier steht dort wo es
hingehört in ihrem zimmer für die beiden
mädchen ist dubai nicht mehr eine
exotische destination sondern die heimat
und so gehen ihre träume bereits wieder
in die welt hinaus
[Musik]
wer weiß vielleicht gehen chiara und
selina in einigen jahren auch auf und
davon
sie stiegen
denn wie gesagt auf der suche nach dem
glück geht der mensch zuweilen weite
wege das paradies wählen wir meist dort
wo wir nicht sind in der ferne ab dem
siebten januar können sie neue abenteuer
von schweizer auswanderern miterleben
auf der götter insel bali entstand das
ferienressort von anni kuhn und orlando
statt
sie mussten manches hindernis überwinden
bis zu diesem kuss
[Musik]
der weg ins glück ist steil aber er
führt die zwei ins farbenfroh leben
ihrer neuen heimat berlin
die geschichte von anni und orlando ist
die geschichte von der liebe zweier
menschen die weit weg von der schweiz
ihr glück suchen
die suche nach einem besseren leben für
jenny und ali wettstein diesem söhnchens
wenn nach peru in lima wollen sie sich
mit einer pasta fabrik und einem
restaurant eine existenz aufbauen
in der freizeit waren sie ausflüge in
den dschungel
[Musik]
ein leben auf einem romantischen landgut
in italien
davon träumen viele schweizerinnen und
schweizer anja kinski und claude wegmann
haben sie diesen traum erfüllt in san
martino stehen sie aber schnell fest
dass für deutsche familien die keine
zeit bleibt zusammen mit anja schwester
nina wollen sie das verfallende landgut
in eine schicke pension verwandeln sie
arbeiten hart um ihr märchen wahr werden
zu lassen
stein für stein tag für tag
[Musik]
und dann gibt es jene die dafür geboren
sind an einem bestimmten ort glücklich
zu werden
die familie schönbächler aus biel zieht
nach kanada der holzfäller herrmann und
seine frau christine wussten schon lange
dass sie früher oder später in der
kanadischen wildnis fernab der
zivilisation leben würden
denn wünsche und träume geht es im leben
von uns allen
und darum wie und wo wir unser glück
finden
zwei spieler sagt er jetzt
witzany workwear bestimmung zugeführt
werden
dies alles und mehr in der neuen staffel
von auf und davon
abenteuer von schweizer auswanderern ab
dem siebten januar auf sf 1
[Musik]
auf uns davon